what's up guys bang bang this video is
brought to you by prime xbt
they are a crypto trading platform that
has an excellent award-winning
environment for margin trading if you
want to go check out
their crypto trading be sure to check
out their copy trading module which
allows you to replicate the trades of
the most successful traders with a
proven track record
if you're interested you can register
with the link below and you can get a
50 deposit bonus go check them out at
prime
xbt and let's get into this interview
all right guys bang bang i've got a very
special treat for you today i've got
james here thank you so much for doing
this
thanks for having me this is going to be
fun absolutely let's just jump right
into your background
we're going to talk about all kinds of
crazy stuff today but uh just kind of
give people context in terms of what
you've done previously and kind of what
got you into the longevity space
absolutely so yeah james pyre um i
started my career as a scientist so i
did a
phd focused on the stem cells
in the blood um worked on
leukemia worked on stem cell transplants
then
uh knew that i wanted to get into drug
discovery
um so switched um consulted for some big
pharma companies for a while
launched a vc fund which was the first
vc fund to focus on longevity
um or to build companies around around
this longevity topic
and then now for the last couple years
we just came out of stealth a few days
ago
um i i teamed up with a
co-founder christian angermeier to start
this company called
cambrian which is we call it a
distributed drug discovery company or a
disco
focused on aging um i got into this
space
actually really early in my life when i
was a teenager my
grandfather uh was dying of cancer
and and i you know was a hot shot kind
of arrogant
know it all and tried to to learn
whatever i could
about his disease and i came to this
really depressing conclusion
which is that we were treating all the
diseases of aging
like cancer wrong that we were waiting
for these diseases to happen to us
and only then trying to use medicines to
unwind them
and that was fundamentally the wrong way
to approach these diseases that we
should instead
understand them try to attack them
before they appear
and only then could we cure them and so
i've been spending my entire life
chasing that idea
so let's get into a little bit when we
talk about disease um
there's a lot of people who just say hey
we get older of course that happens to
everyone
um i think that the uh conversation is
changing a little bit to this idea of
like aging is a disease
uh but i wanna break down like what
exactly is happening as you
age um and kind of why there's a growing
portion of people who believe that we
can actually treat that prevent it delay
it you know kind of all these different
aspects and so uh first let's maybe
start with like the nine hallmarks of
aging
i know that you guys have done a ton of
work of identifying these and explaining
them and kind of elaborating on it but
what does it mean
when you talk about the nine hallmarks
of aging yeah
so i think this is really the right
place to start
um so the nine hallmarks of aging are
basically
nine different types of molecular damage
that build up in our bodies as we get
older
and so you know we don't just you don't
just get cancer
right the moment you know it doesn't
just appear it happens
over a very long period of time where
different
aspects of our bodies are breaking down
little by little in the case of cancer
you have dna mutations that accumulate
one after
the other uh creating an evolutionarily
a selective pressure for some cells to
outcompete others until you kind of
you know run this cycle long enough that
you have this uncontrolled tumor
and but the damage that starts all of
that that
are mutations in our dna that happen
randomly even you know in our 20s and
30s that are constantly happening
um way before we get cancer
and there are nine of these types of
damage that include
um you know chronic inflammation that
happens you know just more and more as
we get older
build up of aggregates like the
aggregates that cause that cause
alzheimer's disease
uh but there are more than just amyloid
and tau aggregates
that are building up all the time and
the machiner that machinery
that we have the recycling mechanisms
for chewing up those aggregates
degrades over time as our cells and our
tissues get older
and so there are this this group of
scientists in this emerging field called
geroscience right the study of what
makes us age have
mapped out way more than nine particular
mechanisms but they fall into these nine
categories that we call the hallmarks of
aging which define the different types
of
damage and and what we've been able to
do with those nine
categories which were only kind of
distilled into a single
thesis about uh seven
years ago to 2013-2014
what we've been able to do since then is
you pick
one of those types of damage and you
tweak it right
either preventing it from building up or
removing it from an already aged animal
and we see this amazing thing happen
which is
you can take a mouse for example tweak
one of these hallmarks of aging and it
just
lives longer and healthier than it ever
would in the past so instead of living
you know for a mouse like two and a half
years
it's living three or more years instead
and instead of getting sick at two years
so that it dies at two and a half years
it's
only getting sick at you know two and a
half
or close to three years and and that
change is fundamentally what gets me
excited about this space because that
would mean
you know if we could translate that into
human biology
like it would be way better than like a
magical cure for cancer
or something like that as far as like
the number of extra healthy
years of life we could distribute to the
population
um we can talk about that a little bit
more yeah
so what i want to talk about is just you
know at a very high level uh when you
talk about molecular damage
um just explain that very quickly for
people because i think that that's uh
somewhat table stakes in the kind of the
scientific community and the longevity
community
but there's a lot of people who won't
understand what that actually means sure
so you know we're all just collections
of cells
cells are bags of fat containing water
protein dna and you know
and other molecules right and
the molecules that make up our bodies
are
changing dynamically all the time and so
so we're constantly being assaulted with
you know uv rays
from the sun or crap that we put into
our bodies that we eat
or even just like random changes
uh as we get older where like our the
bags that are
our bodies are not designed to live or
to function forever
in an unchanging state and as
as these different you know
environmental and natural
impacts affect our
our cells and our tissues things change
over time um so let me try to do a
better job of explaining what
molecularly we mean here right
and i think that would actually help to
maybe touch on the nine hallmarks of
aging
really really briefly just so we know
what what we're talking about
at cambrian we separate these into three
categories
of changes that we think of as like
changes
inside the cell so i already mentioned
in cancer we have mutations to the dna
but also as our cells divide the ends of
our chromosomes called the telomeres
which uh you and some of the listeners
may have heard of they get
shorter every time a cell divides right
and so that's another kind of molecular
damage in a way because our cells are
becoming less able to do more divisions
every time they divide so
then there's also inside the cell a loss
of what's called epigenetic information
so this is some of the markers on top of
the dna
that yeah that change which genes are
expressed in which cells at which time
and the more information is lost there
the
less well the cells perform the job that
they're supposed to do
then we have a second category of like
whole cellular level dysfunction so
cells themselves can become old and
dysfunctional
we call this cellular senescence where
they were supposed to die
but actually fail to do so and they
operate
they start operating in this different
program that spews inflammatory
cytokines so basically inflammatory
molecules out into the environment
and they can cause quite a lot of havoc
even if you only have
one one out of every hundred cells being
in this senescent state
and similarly another kind of like whole
cellular level dysfunction
we have the power plants in our cells
the mitochondria that make energy
those start working less and less well
over time as
our bodies get older and so those might
the the power plants can become
dysfunctional and
there's a few different types of
molecular damage that can make
mitochondria
not work well so this is kind of a
second theme
of cellular level dysfunctions and then
the
final theme is tissue level dysfunctions
so we have
stem cells in our tissues right that are
trying to regenerate
uh especially when we're young
regenerate injured organs our liver is
super good at regenerating for example
our bone marrow
our immune systems are super good at
regenerating but as we get older
the stem cells that are fueling all of
that they get worn out
over time and and they are able to
regenerate less and less well
um another one that's in this kind of
like organismal level
or you know whole tissue level is
uh the topic of chronic inflammation
um so long-term chronic inflammation
does
horrible things to a tissue it turns it
from
being very flexible and and
flexible and regenerative to what we
call fibrotic basically
we become more and more like a scar as
we get older
not just on our skin but in all of our
tissues and so
we're spending a lot of time thinking
about this increased
scarification that happens not just in
our skin but in our liver and our
kidneys
our hearts our lungs as we get older and
what
molecular tools we could use to reverse
some of that
to to make our tissues more more
flexible
more able to regenerate um instead of
hardening up
so it gets into a little bit of
scientific detail but hopefully gives a
sense of like the types of damage
that we're thinking about um in this jar
science field
yeah and what's so interesting about
this i think that there's a sequence
that people
may or may not understand which is that
a lot of this molecular damage
happens in what most would consider your
healthy years
and then it actually shows up you know
10 20 30 years later
and so maybe talk through a little bit
of like that sequencing around
um the when the damage happens but then
also like when it shows up and how
that's not actually happening
simultaneously in most cases
exactly i think that that's the key to
understanding this whole field
is that um when like
when someone is diagnosed with a disease
like alzheimer's
let's say that that alzheimer's
diagnosis
is it's like not the start of the
disease
it's one inflection point of a really
long process that's been happening
in that person um and
and so what this field
of aging biology or general science is
helping people think about
is that
if we can understand all of the damage
that's building up
10 years 20 years 30 years before what
we call a phenotypic effect
right so before someone is actually
losing their memory or unable to walk or
unable to eat
or something like that that can happen
to a patient with alzheimer's or in the
case of
you know cancer before you see a big
tumor that's metastasizing if we can
understand that damage
in the 10 20 30 years leading up to it
measure that damage and then use a
biomedical intervention
to either stop it or reverse it before
we get a disease
then it's a much easier problem to solve
than it is to try to react to a disease
once it's already happened um
and and i actually have like a kind of
nerdy scientific uh
way that i l example that i like to use
to think about this
um so as a vc in in bio
we invest in companies like cancer
companies for example right and one of
the ways that drugs are tested
in cancer companies is you give a mouse
a tumor and then try your experimental
treatment to see if the
mouse can clear out its tumor right and
so
it's you know pretty standard practice
you're giving my
mice cancer curing the cancer and then
you can like use that as a justification
for trying it in humans later but
as a vc one thing that we all do is we
make sure in these mouse models of
cancer that before we try our
experimental treatments
that the the mouse has been injected
with the tumor and the tumor has like
grown big and scary enough
that you know it's going to be hard to
for the for the treatment to clear out
that tumor because
if you treat the mouse too early when
the cancer is just developing
we know that almost every anti-cancer
treatment
works really really well and you get
like 100 cure rates
but that doesn't then translate into
good results for patients
human patients that have advanced tumors
and so
it's this fascinating situation to me
and i guess you know a bit a bit nerdy
here
um that like we're turning the thinking
on its head
where like a lot of the vc and
investment thesis in how we think about
mouse models has been
how do we make sure we can replicate
advanced stage human disease
in the mice so that the mice that we're
treating look more like the patients
that we're treating
that's one way to think about uh this
investment thesis but
but this geru science hypothesis almost
turns it on its head which is like
if we know a way that we can cure cancer
almost
every single time why don't we start
thinking about how we
treat our human patients in the way that
works almost every time
in our mouse models and i think that
that kind of flipping of the script
is is the powerful one of the powerful
ideas behind this
one of the most fascinating things to me
uh in all of this uh was when i learned
about brett weinstein and kind of a lot
of the controversy around
uh the mice and the shortening of
telomeres and kind of how a bunch of the
mice came from the same place and
uh without getting you know super into
detail about that whole situation people
can go
google it but uh it really just showed
that like hey this is still science
and if you don't get kind of a bunch of
stuff right uh the conclusion can be
inaccurate
um and so this whole idea of like what's
the framework you use right do you try
to replicate the human disease and
a mouse and then uh go ahead and address
it or do we just figure out how do we
cure mice and then
should we bring that to the humans is a
fascinating way um to kind of look at it
what i want to talk about uh next is
this idea of healthy years and christian
and i have talked a ton about this
and i think that a lot of people uh when
they think of longevity they just simply
say
okay well if the average human lifespan
is 77 78 years whatever it is now
uh how do we get that to 80 and then how
do we get that to 85
90 100. um and yeah that makes sense
because you just want to live more years
but but actually there's a difference
between
living for an extra 20 years at the
healthy
or unhealthy state of a 90 year old
versus living an extra 20 healthy years
that
might actually be more like you know
what you feel
and how you operate at 45 not actually
feeling the effects of older age until
maybe you're
65 and then being able to kind of
capture those healthy years so talk a
little bit just how you think about
healthy years versus maybe non-healthy
years and why it's so important
to focus on the former rather than the
latter yeah
and i i think you you nailed our thesis
uh right off the bat there which is if
we only extend
unhealthy the unhealthy period at the
end of life
we're doing a disservice rather than a
service
to the population at large so anything
that's worth doing has to extend
the number of healthy years and like
that's our ultimate readout so whenever
we talk about it
we actually avoid the term lifespan
altogether unless it has the term
healthy put before it or
you know i think the most popular term
among the people in our field is
actually to talk about in terms of
health span
as one word or my favorite again kind of
wonky term which is
qualis the quality adjusted life years
where this is kind of how insurance
companies
uh think about you know quantifying
human human life happiness kind of that
that uh cross product and
and so the positive news here
is what we've seen both in humans as our
lifespans have risen
from 35 at you know
120 years ago at the the start of the
1900s
to close to 80 now
we've seen as human lifespan has gone up
human healthy lifespan has also gone up
dramatically
obviously because we're dying of these
chronic and horrible diseases like
cancer and cardiovascular disease and
alzheimer's now
there is a tail period of unhealthiness
that most of us
experience at the end of our lives um
but but in humans we have been able to
extend that healthy lifespan portion out
very significantly
and in mice and other model organisms
that we've been able to
use drug interventions to extend those
healthy the healthy lifespan of those
animals you you're basically
never able to increase just the
unhealthy portion of life
because one of the conclusions or i
guess the
assumptions from this damage theory of
aging
is that once you've got a critical
amount of damage that's going to send
you kind of tumbling downhill
which will ultimately result in your in
the organism's death
like you can't undo that
that hill from that inflection point so
it's a much simpler idea
to extend the time before you reach that
that turning point
that starts you tumbling downhill and so
when i talked a little bit about like
the mouse life extension earlier
you extend like the way that essentially
all of these treatments work as you
extend that healthy period
and then the period of decline that
ultimately ends in the death of the
organism
actually stays fairly constant because
once you've reached that big threshold
then there's almost just nothing you can
do and it's a matter of time
got it let's think through a little bit
um
there's multiple i think schools of
thought around prevention
reversal and then maybe i'll just call
it treatment right like you're already
kind of old and burst gonna make it as
uh
as painless as possible and as enjoyable
as possible
how do you look at those three buckets
right kind of prevention reversal or
treatment uh and is one better than the
other
uh is it kind of um no we need to do all
three at the same time
to get the best outcome just what's the
framework you use to think through that
it's a really good question that we
could probably spend an hour
uh talking about to to give justice um
but but i will put it in in kind of
almost like an easiest to hardest term
sort of terms where prevention is always
scientifically the easiest thing to do
but from a uh a treatment perspective
both
getting drugs approved through the you
know regulatory system like the fda
but but also in like choosing which
patients to treat
prevention is the hardest so
scientifically easiest
practically the most difficult
treatment is scientifically in some ways
the hardest like it's much harder to
unwind these diseases
after they've already appeared and
but from a regulatory perspective it's
much easier because that's how our
health care system is set up today
it's set up to be reactive waiting for
someone to get sick
and then now we know like we can approve
a drug to see if you know it can
you know shrink your cancer or something
like this
but the sad reality is that we haven't
developed
enough drugs that can work
it worked that well in a lot of people
so like if you look at the past
75 drugs that have been approved in to
treat cancer
over the last 10 years the
average amount of extra time a cancer
patient gets when they go on to one of
these drugs
is about two and a half months of extra
life right
not a huge bonus for the fact that we're
spending
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
conducting clinical trials and cancer
therapy
and so it's not zero progress at all and
there's tons of of good
uh good discoveries being made but it's
just such a scientifically harder
problem
than than prevention um
and then the final one around reversal
like this is
in some ways you know
in some contexts you could think of
reversal as treatment
um and so let's say in the context of
cancer reversal
probably isn't an option all right like
once you've got a cancer you can't just
like
reverse the damage that caused the
cancer from being there
because if you would it would just be a
treatment for the cancer
so reversal is really something that you
have to think about in a tissue
specific or a disease specific sort of
way
um where it's like before you have
something that's going to definitely
kill you
but when there's still time to undo the
damage so it kind of sits somewhere in
between
treatment and prevention and
and so i'll give like a couple of
examples here like let's say
i'm getting into my 70s or 80s
and my muscles are becoming way weaker
right
and my bones are becoming way weaker so
this is now
already happening to me i'm getting less
less robust and we could try to use a
therapy to
strengthen my muscles to strengthen the
structure of my bones
so that i don't continue to get more
frail kind of like resetting me back to
the point where i was in my
40s or something along those lines from
a
scientific point of view that's harder
than
the uh the prevention aspect but
not as hard as trying to you know put me
back together
once i've had a fall in my late 80s and
my hip is shattered
um and then from a regulatory
perspective it actually looks a lot like
the prevention part
because again we're weakening but we
haven't been diagnosed with a major
disease
the fda kind of looks at all of that in
the same in the same way
and so a lot of what we focus on
is this reversal and prevention ideas
and we kind of
bundle those together into one way of
thinking about like
medicines that we can use before a true
disease
happens that's either preventing damage
from building up or reversing it once
it's there
that's the same category for us
everything you're talking about is uh
incredibly
complex and there's a lot of really
really smart people working on it
and there's a lot of people who um are
doing it for what i'll call kind of the
right reasons
in terms of uh they want to make a
difference they want to
increase life they want to have people
live healthier lives there's also people
who are doing it
from a for-profit um kind of perspective
and uh profit is kind of the number one
uh thing that they're focused on uh i
don't think neither do i think that you
nor christian
uh believe that those two things have to
be mutually exclusive like i actually
think that there's a world here where
uh you could take a capitalistic
perspective uh and
the capitalism or the pursuit of profits
actually drives uh
revenue which then can be reinvested to
further um kind of the the
health impact and probably is the most
sustainable model that we've seen so far
but you guys have a spin or kind of a
variation of how to finance a lot of
this work
um and one of the things that i think is
fascinating to me
is that most of the people in this space
come from the science side right
they look at it from a very scientific
perspective uh
and there's a constant uh cat and mouse
game how do i get funding how do i get a
grant how do i get
uh some level of uh financial uh kind of
backing so that i can actually
spend time uh both mentally and um
and kind of uh with resources to
actually make an impact
you guys are looking at this in kind of
this drug discovery company model so
maybe talk a little bit about
uh this disco like dis co that you guys
uh talk about a lot
uh and then talk through what are the
variations or changes that you think of
from a financing perspective that
uh should lead to kind of a better uh
outcome and
a more kind of sustainable platform yeah
so there's
there's a lot of threads that i can pick
up from there
um but but maybe before we jump deep
into the
the disco model i want to just emphasize
one of the pieces that you're talking
about or i'm like
doing this for the right reasons kind of
how drug discovery in general
works because there are
you know a few different ways that
people have been doing this
and i think that as you articulated the
biggest problem
for folks trying to think about
developing a drug for anything
is the funding question that a lot of
drugs that start clinical trials
ultimately end up failing and
that those failures are usually very
expensive
to figure out because it takes you know
tens or even hundreds of millions of
dollars to run a phase one then a phase
two
and then a phase three clinical trial
we've seen that you know with
uh with the coveted vaccines that
everyone has paid attention to these are
incredibly expensive
human experiments to run
and so um one of the cool things
about the pharmaceutical industry as it
exists in the free market
for all of its flaws and it has many
is that once you start going down a path
that's going to cost 100 million dollars
plus to
get you from an idea stage to an
approved drug
that at the end of that it really never
makes sense to start to say like oh well
this is just going to be for one small
group of people
right that you you actually want to get
those drugs
to as many people as possible at the
right price
um and so there's there's this old joke
in the pharma industry that it takes a
billion dollars to make your first pill
and it takes a fraction of a penny to
make your second one
uh and that what what that means for
supply and demand curves is that
when a medicine is applicable to a large
fraction of the population
it drives the price way way way down and
so the closest thing that exists
today to what we would think of as one
of these
gyro protective or age slowing drugs
is actually the drug lipitor so these
statins that reduce cholesterol that's
the closest
the the closest equivalent to what's
been on the market so far
and those drugs at their highest point
never cost
more than four or five dollars a day
right
and it was the most profitable drug of
all time
because it reached so many people and so
when we think about doing this for the
right reasons and kind of like the
mixing and matching of the the profit
motive
with the with drug development i think
there is actually kind of a positive
story there so i just wanted to pick up
on that thread
the the second piece that you talked
about
as it relates to how we fund drug
development today
um we've actually been in this
really interesting quiet revolution
where two things are changing a lot in
science
and the first part is that universities
and like academic research scientists
because of all of the genetic sequencing
tools and like
advances in chemistry advances in
genetics that have been happening
so you can do so much more
now in a university lab than you could
20 or 30 years ago
as far as making a drug and so almost
all
like the majority of new drugs are
actually discovered at universities
spun out into biotech companies and then
are eventually acquired
by big pharmaceutical companies that do
the late stage clinical trials
because this is working so well on the
flip side
the big pharma companies are actually
powering down
their r d and and relying more and more
on
gobbling up through m a these small
research companies right and so the
intersection of those two things
means that there's tons of good ideas
inside of academia
that need to do the research and
development work to prove to a big
pharma player
that their idea is worth a damn and so
they're constantly
fighting for funding um and so the vcs
the funders have kind of become the
gatekeepers in this um
and and you have this really kind of
messy mixture of like ceos coming into a
biotech company pitching a vc to try to
get funding
and then you know getting a little bit
of data pitching more vcs bringing more
in until you can kind of like finally
roll a big enough snowball to get
absorbed by by a pharma company um but
it's really messy
it involves a lot of hype generation and
and like a lot of like who you know
sort of conversations um and
ultimately what we've seen is that it
can get disconnected from the
value of the underlying science and so
when
christian and i came into this field
what we wanted to do
was build an organization that could
have this
scale to take a lot of different shots
on goal
so that some of them would ultimately
succeed and
and then at the individual asset
development level
make our decisions exclusively based on
the quality of the science
not on you know how hyped it was or what
the last valuation was or
who who had invested before um and so
with with cambridge we've been able to
like absorb
15 almost 15 different projects that
started at universities into our
umbrella
and now we can continue to resource the
ones that are working
with more and more money to kind of get
them into clinical trials
and if an idea fails like that's a tough
message to deliver to that team
but it's better for us as the ultimate
like the organization that's footing the
bill
to make that decision early instead of
trying to pull more and more capital and
like hype it up and hype it up
try to like get it out the door and then
have it ultimately fall on its face
and so that's a bit of a
you know a lecture on this and we can go
deeper or stay at a higher level as how
this model works
but changing those incentives around so
that i can talk to
my ultimate investors and not have to
sell them a bill of goods
around how this one technology is going
to change the world
but instead say hey look we have this
thesis around
how we're going to create this new
category of of
preventative or proactive medicines
targeting the hallmarks of aging and if
you
believe that this hypothesis has merit
to it
we're going to take enough shots on goal
to get
one two three four things working
and we and we don't need every single
project
to uh to ultimately be you know the
golden goose
i think that's a very powerful idea
absolutely
and so you guys recently came out of
stealth you've been working on this for
i think about two years or so
what can you share in terms of who some
of the investors are and kind of how you
guys have been funded today
yeah so um so cambrian
is a biotech company not a vc fund
all right so we actually have attracted
investors that are
traditional company investors started
this together with
christian angermeier who runs a piran
investment group
who's also behind a few other really
interesting
projects including one called a tie that
is
um commercializing all of the
psychedelics
uh for use in mental health disorders
and actually running clinical trials and
those
um so christian is the biggest a single
investor in cambrian
but then we've also attracted a really
really good group of other folks i can't
talk about all of them um
but uh but among them are future
ventures
which is steve jefferson and mariana
syanco's fund
um steve was one of the early investors
on the
end on the board of like tesla and
spacex and it's just like
they are just really far thinkers about
what the
future is going to look like have been
huge supporters
mike novogratz who is a bit who's really
big in the crypto space
as well as doing a ton of other smart
investments
uh also involved in in the psychedelics
work
um brent saunders who's the former ceo
of allergan
uh which was acquired for 50 plus
billion
uh by advi um is really interested in
this space and then
uh a biotech specific bc based out of
baltimore called catalio
um also participated with us so we've
got this kind of like cool group of
eminent tech investors entrepreneurs
some folks from the crypto world
kind of like all coming together to
to support this mission for cambrian um
and we've raised 60 million so far um
but i've
i can say kind of like on this not off
the record but like not on paper
sort of format that that i've had the uh
the luxury of being able to turn down
about three times as much money as we've
accepted
um which is a really cool place to be
absolutely and
and so part of this is obviously uh
financing is an important part of the
the drug development
and kind of distribution uh and you've
got
a recent announcement sensei and
there's been a kind of a public market
angle to this maybe talk a little bit
about what
exactly is sensei how does that fit into
the cambrian model and then
talk a little bit whatever you can share
in terms of the public market
yeah absolutely so so sensei is a cancer
vaccines company that we started working
with right when we started cambrian
um that was had already completed a
phase one clinical trial
and needed funding to start its phase
two clinical trial we partnered with
them
around that um before
touching a little bit on like what their
product specifically does i want to put
it in the context of like why this fits
in cambrian and so every program that we
put together
has to have two features um
the first feature is that it has to
target one of our
hallmarks of aging right and and if it
targets one of the hallmarks of aging
you know we think it can ultimately be
used as a
preventative or a you know either a
prevention or reversal
therapy somewhere down the line but the
key is somewhere down the line
it has to also on the other hand be able
to be built
as a real biotech company that can
deliver
you know short to medium term value for
investors
today within the existing regulatory
environment
and so what got us excited about sensei
is that
these guys had figured out how to make a
cancer vaccine
that you could give to patients with an
already established cancer
they would kind of like do some
sequencing kind of measure some of the
the genes that were overexpressed in
that tumor
make a cancer vaccine
to that could boost the person's immune
system to attack the cancer cells
and it was working right um and we don't
have to go too much into the specific
details but
but basically at the you know not the 30
000 foot level but at the
1000 foot level in order to
turn your immune system on to attack
cancer cells
you need to trick it into thinking that
that the cancer cells are virally
infected
and so what these guys have done is
they've taken a hollowed-out virus
that normally infects bacteria doesn't
affect human cells
and layered cancer proteins on top of it
injected it into a person that person's
immune system
noms on that uh bacteria virus with the
cancer proteins
first realizes oh hey i've been like it
looks like there's a viral infection
here
what should we respond to and as it
chops up all the different pieces
it shows the immune system all of these
cancer proteins which then as the immune
system starts to look around the body
for like where these
quote unquote virally infected cells are
it finds all the tumor cells
and and that that is kind of like a
something that people in the cancer
immunotherapy field have been trying to
do for
15 years um and i haven't seen done
as successfully until i met
sensei and discovered their platform so
that's that's kind of like
how how this works but the
really cool thing about this is in
addition to treating people with stage
four
metastatic you know cancer people who
have no other options left
which is the people that sensei has been
treating right now and actually been
able to
help a substantial fraction of them we
think
um in addition to that the platform has
this really cool
potential which is i don't know uh
how much you and your listeners have
paid attention to some of the stuff like
there's this thing called a liquid
biopsy um that's been developed just in
the last couple of years
which is like before you could even
detect a tumor in your body
you can start detecting like single cell
single tumor cells circulating in the
blood
um and and people have been able to pick
up oh
can we use advanced sequencing
techniques to like find those tumor
cells in the blood
and so in the longer term we could
imagine using this vaccine technology
not just to treat people with no hope
left
but to actually go in for like regular
checkups to see if there's any little
bits of tumor cells in our body
vaccinating ourselves there before we
even detect a tumor
to prevent a tumor from happening and
then even in the long term
to to use a technology like this the
same way that we have
hpv vaccines to prevent cervical cancer
why couldn't you do this with other
proteins to prevent
lots of different types of cancers it is
very theoretically possible
and it's just a matter of building a
platform that's both powerful enough and
we think
safe enough to to justify doing that
and so that's where sensei's long-term
vision is so that's
yeah a little bit of an overview there
of what got us excited about it
and talk a little bit about the public
market aspect to it and why that's so
important
absolutely so
so i talked a little bit already about
this kind of change in supply and demand
right as university program university
spin-out programs and these small
biotech companies
have become the wellspring from which
all new medicines arise and
and so the natural history of these
companies goes in
one of two different directions either
they get gobbled up by a big pharma
company or they raise a bunch of funding
and can kind of go up go it on their own
which usually involves
a path into the public markets and
especially since covid with you know
clinical trial data being on the front
page of the new york times the wall
street journal every day
regular investors have started to get
biotech
so much more than they did in the past
and they're they're able to make
informed decisions
about what's you know what's uh what's
working and what's not
by looking at these uh clinical stage
biotech companies
and so the the ipo market for biotechs
has exploded
in the last couple of years and so
um by bringing sensei public we can do a
couple of things
number one we've been able to resource
its
clinical programs so that it can get all
the way into what's called a pivotal
trial
right the the trial that would give it
the ability to approve a drug
all on its own with with the money that
we raised from
ipo investors which often is just like a
much higher number
because once you're publicly traded
those investors aren't stuck with an
asset that they don't want right
they can sell off their shares later
they want to um
and then the the second benefit is that
from
cambrian's perspective it was really
valuable for us to take
this affiliate company of ours into the
public markets
because it's kind of a validation for
the way that we source
resource and build assets for our whole
portfolio
so we were able to take this company
that had you know a little bit of data
but like was right at a point where we
could accelerate it dramatically
by getting involved and and generated
nearly 600 million dollars of value
in you know a year and a half a little
bit more
by by pushing the gas on this one asset
and
and that value is now validated in the
public markets because this is what
people are freely trading the stock at
um and that's a cool place to be
what do you think is the um the kind of
biggest lesson that you've learned over
the last two years that would surprise
people
right the thing that uh you didn't
expect or the thing that you didn't
understand
but now you look back and you say hey
here's the one learning that i've had
that uh that would be just absolutely
fascinating for people to understand
that's a really good question so
i think the thing that's probably been
most surprising
to me throughout all of this is
just how segmented and
like and fractured the drug development
ecosystem is
where like the university professors
really can't even speak the same
language
as the guys at the pharma companies who
are ultimately developing drugs
and there's such a wide gap of data
and understanding there that that the
folks who are kind of like coming into
the middle to fill in this gap and
actually like
build biotech companies that bridge this
gap
it's way way wider than i expected
um and let's see if i can put this
a little bit more concretely with a
story uh
here so yeah and maybe i think it's
useful to get into just like a little
bit of the detail around this so so in
order to get a drug
approved right we talked about the three
phases of clinical trials
but you also need to run all of these
safety studies
before you go into humans and you have
to validate that your drug is working in
a million different ways
and when i was a phd student
uh working in the lab on on mice i
didn't i
didn't know and wasn't taught a single
one of these things
that had to be done right it was all
about could i
generate like some interesting discovery
that i could publish about in a paper
and you know get it in some journal and
then move on to the next thing that
would be the next discovery
and and so now that i'm in the middle
here
i see that there's about you know 500
experiments
that need to be done from that first
observation which you know gets covered
in
the new york times or whatever like as
oh wow we've made this huge discovery in
mice
there's about 500 things that then need
to be done before someone at a pharma
company will say
oh yeah it looks like you have something
really interesting here
and figuring out what those 500 things
are and building the right
teams together of chemists and
toxicologists and
pharmacologists and like uh you know
patients and all of these other people
that have to come together to think
about
how we formulate this drug and how we
treat it and how we've tested it in all
the right ways
it's such an operation and and so
that's really why this process
this process is so expensive to go from
university to
uh to ultimately getting a clinical
ready product but also why there's so
much opportunity
for companies to add a ton of value
there because there really is
this you know really ripe landscape
for for picking great ideas out of
universities and if you can
be that translation engine both
translation in the
literal sense of like being able to
speak the language of the
of the folks who will ultimately be uh
working with you but also you know
translating the discovery from the mouse
stage to the human stage
it's just a great business that's adding
a lot of value to the healthcare system
what's the biggest obstacle or challenge
right obviously uh you're an optimistic
person
so am i so is christian um i think that
we generally have confidence
uh given who the backers are uh what you
guys are working on
that um there's a lot of progress
that'll be made here uh but what would
the argument of the detractors be or
kind of what would be the identification
of what those obstacles and challenges
are
so so the biggest biggest obstacle for
us
like as i have my eye on the next decade
of what we need to do
is establishing the regulatory paradigms
to do prevention
when we value cambrian right now it's
entirely based upon what we can do with
the drugs that we have in the existing
regulatory regime which is essentially
entirely
reactive and so so
the biggest challenges that we're
thinking about now are how do we
create the
create the pile of data that we're going
to need to convince
these regulators the regulators that we
have to work with and to the fda's
credit they've been
open to having a conversation with us on
this
but how do we create the pile of data
that will allow us to say
hey we you know we have this drug it
works in cancer or it works in like some
rare childhood disease we want to see if
it can slow down aging
and actually get them to say yes because
the way that the fda works
now is they would allow us to run a
trial for slowing down
aging or preventing multiple diseases
but you know
if you and i started taking you know you
start taking the drug i start taking the
placebo right now
it'll take 30 or 40 years for us to know
whether it worked or not
and even if you start treating people in
their 60s it'll still it would still
take
10 or 15 years whether you would know it
was if it was working or not
and so what we need to do is find the
right tools
like what was done with cholesterol and
these statin drugs
right where people you know could come
and say oh you have high cholesterol
let's put you on the drug
if your cholesterol goes down we can
actually approve the drug already
get it out into the market get it into
people's hands but then follow up those
patients for another 10 years to see
if they actually get fewer strokes
actually get fewer heart attacks
we have to do the same sort of thing
here but that's just something that
doesn't exist in the aging space yet
um and we're going to be working very
closely with
with the fda but also with other
countries who are
um excited about exploring this kind of
transformational technology
before i go to uh kind of the rapid fire
questions to wrap up
uh what's the message to people right
when they would think of
cambrian when they think of the work
that you're doing
what is that one thing that you want
them to walk away for
remembering or kind of what that mission
is
so what i would say here
is that the 1900s
in medicine were defined by our conquest
of our biggest human predators at the
time which were viral and bacterial
diseases
and the combination of vaccines and
antibiotics led us into a new era
where now our biggest predators are
age-related diseases
heart disease cancer alzheimer's etc
and and the way that we
conquered those diseases in the 20th
century
is going to be applicable to how we
conquer the age-related diseases
in the 21st century by understanding
what causes them
before people completely break down from
those diseases
and and devising treatments to in some
cases proactively
and in some cases at the very early
stages of the disease use the power of
medicine to reverse them
and and that's how in this century we're
going to overcome
today's biggest predators it's a it's a
you know a transition from being
reactive to proactive that's going to
happen
at some point this decade and we want to
be on the
cutting edge of of eliciting that
transition
that's fantastic um i always ask the
same three questions to everyone before
i let them go and then you get to ask me
when to finish up the first is what is
the most important book that you've ever
read
so my god pick one
uh probably richard dawkins the selfish
gene
i think that is for me you know i almost
tell people it's the grounding of my
philosophy
in some ways to understand how
the logic of evolution really works
and it's been incredibly impactful to me
in thinking about this topic of aging
and
longevity because you know we have to
remember that evolution isn't here to
serve
us our you know our bodies that are
thinking and doing interesting things
it it has we have all evolved to serve
our genes
on an individual level and the fact that
we are able to
you know think about the universe and
have fun conversations like this one
is an evolutionary accident in a lot of
ways and so we have to take
responsibility
if we want to preserve what what we have
here
um kind of like taking that into our own
hands so
i would say yeah selfish gene with an
honor an honorable mention to
a book called uh the origin of wealth by
eric beinhacker about how markets work
with the same mathematical principles as
the biology of evolution
i love that answer uh second question a
little bit more personal
brought to you by our friends over at
eat sleep they've got a thermoregulation
bed that essentially allows for you to
make it hotter or colder
i'm a really really cold get deep sleep
and not feel much better
but i used to only sleep five or six
hours now i sleep like eight or nine
uh what's your sleep routine and kind of
how's that evolved over the years
so i'm also sleep cold kind of guy sleep
sleep cold but with like a nice blanket
um and and i try to go to bed at the
same
time uh every single night i go for like
seven and a half to eight hours of sleep
for me although
eight to nine i definitely like i think
there's a lot of evidence that getting
up into that range is way better for you
um and yeah
and then i guess without taking too much
time my sleep has evolved quite a lot
over my life um when i was a grad
student i tried to
you know before a lot of this sleep
research was done i was trying to
actually shorten my sleeping hours
to get more done in the lab
and i got so i became such an [ __ ] to
people when my sleep was getting down to
like five or six hours a day
that i abandoned it and spent two years
during graduate school
operating on a 28-hour circadian rhythm
where i would sleep for eight hours and
then stay up for 20
and had six days in a week instead of
seven so i was up at like really weird
uh weird hours and you know that was
great when i
wasn't dating anybody and didn't really
have any friends and just needed to be
working in the lab
but but now i'm trying to be a little
bit more disciplined
i love the uh the experimentation with
sleep
uh i've even tried i think they call it
the everyman
sleep schedule which is like four hours
of sleep but split into
an hour and a half and then a couple of
30-minute abs in the whole thing
uh polyphasic sleep i think or something
like that um
the third question is is more fun aliens
are you a believer or a non-believer
i i think that they have to be out there
the the drake equation
is a very compelling reason
to think that there are other life forms
out there it's just a matter of finding
them
um i as a as a
i don't know fun little experiment in
college at some point a group of friends
and i were thinking about
alternative answers to the
the fermi paradox right which comes out
of the drake equation basically like
do all evolved civilizations destroy
themselves
and i actually think that there is we
don't have to get deep into this but i
think that there is another compelling
explanation
which is because we've scanned so little
of the sky
for radio transmissions and these other
things
there is a possibility that
interstellar travel is just not often
worth it
right and that it's just so far and
getting up to close to light speeds is
so freaking hard
that even very advanced species end up
just
hugely colonizing their own you know
stellar neighborhood
but not expanding like uh what isaac
asimov once said a ball of flesh
expanding at the speed of light that
that just doesn't happen even for very
advanced civilizations
um so i'm you know a future optimist and
alien believer um i'm right there with
you they they exist we probably won't
engage with them during our lifetime
everything look in the sky is you know
million years old so we'll see depends
how long our lives are i guess
very very true uh what's the one
question you have for me to
wrap up so the question that i think i
would ask you
is as you think about
the future of technology and you ask
yourself like what are the most
important changes that are going to
happen to our civilization
in the next 30 40 50 years
like how do you rank the how do you rank
the biggest
impacts between you know automation of
work
changes to the monetary system climate
change as well as medical innovations
how do you think about ordering those
things in terms of their impact
that's an impossible question
i don't think i could rank them in terms
of like you know a magnitude of
significance what i could say is
uh can i paint a picture of where i
think the world's going um
and of course this gets labeled as kind
of uh you know the sci-fi silicon valley
view of the future
uh but i like to joke all the time and
say like well technologists are right
um and so i think that one you get
kind of uh bioengineered humans uh that
are augmented by
uh technology and computing power either
externally or internally
you get a ton of automation automation
that includes robotics
uh all the way down to literally
streaming payments and uh
digital uh assets like you know
tokenized stocks bonds currencies
commodities etc
uh you get a multi-planetary
species that involves travel both
uh domestically internationally and
kind of multi-planetary and then i think
that what we're going to see
is a drastic shift in the world to kind
of clean renewable energy
um and to you know electric vehicles and
kind of you just like go down the line
like all of this stuff that everyone's
all excited about like yeah sure it
takes longer than we probably want it to
take
but it's all going to happen um and i
think that the
part that probably people are
underestimating the most
is how disruptive the disruption
actually ends up being
and then also too uh we like to think
about you know humans are geniuses we're
gonna build all this stuff
uh but i actually think one of the
craziest uh most exciting
innovations is going to be as we disrupt
ourselves right meaning that
uh when you start thinking about
longevity and people living longer
healthier lives when you start to think
about an augmented human
uh literally with you know the brain
computer interfaces when you start to
think about
uh just what carrying a super computer
in our pocket did well imagine when that
is uh reduced friction and things like
air pods um
you know and kind of what that has
empowered and so i think that it's just
like
we're headed in the right direction uh
what's more important than the rest like
it's all interconnected
right um and so i think that uh you know
just people who
are pessimists uh i'd like to say you
know pessimists are losers
uh because they basically are betting
against innovation they're betting
against progress and i just tend to
think that that's a really really bad
side of the trade to be on
totally fair although as someone who has
a few pessimists on my team
i uh i love the balancing effects no
they're losers
tell them if you're a pessimist you're a
loser now
as much as i joke around about that i i
think that uh you know
it really is you yes you do need some
people with kind of rational belief
uh but i like to remind people that uh
being rational doesn't mean you have to
be a pessimist like you can be a
rational optimist
uh if you kind of think like the matt
ridley view of the world i was gonna say
great another great book that would be
in my top five
as far as recommendations yeah and i
think mash has done a great job of kind
of you know look being rational is
important being an optimist is important
uh but but uh the the whole idea of
being a pessimist especially somebody
who
uh hangs their hat on being a pessimist
or somebody who is um
you know i like to say a lot a a
multi-time violator
of of pessimism uh if you just every
time you see something you're
pessimistic
then uh you know just like hey man jump
over on the other side of the river this
side is a little bit more fun
and i think that rational optimism is
the way to play the uh play the game
awesome well thanks for answering that
pomp this was fun
absolutely listen james thank you so
much for doing this i think people are
really really going to enjoy this
obviously i'm a huge fan of what you and
the christian are building here
and uh think that longevity and a lot of
the work is
just super important to uh to the human
race if you will so uh thanks so much
for all the hard work and i appreciate
taking the time to
have the conversation with it again in
the future okay fantastic
look forward to that